all right let's play with this
Trinity of
emptiness of anti-matrix and of new
Earth so the first one is obviously
about the nature of reality the nature
of mind the fact that the Mind itself is
empty it's spacious it has no qualities
it has no attributes has no identifiers
has no
bounds
um has no name it's nameless it's no one
it's nothing it's everyone it's
everything it's
Timeless it's the Purity the purity of
pure Consciousness pure awareness
itself so it's a huge quote Deon
conditioning
project uh expansion of
contractions um the quote the spiritual
journey and sometimes there can be a
stuckness where okay but what
now what now well
integrate which we have the
perfect second visual
here when you quote when you quote
dissolve what you do is you integrate
you integrate back into the body you
integrate back into form you integrate
back into relativity you integrate back
into the game into the dance into the
beautiful Battlefield into the stage
into the infinity
War the magic the sorcerers is the
magician it's magical at any point it's
completely empty at any point it's
completely present and it's casting all
kinds of spells of
transformation and it's also
idoing so none of those uh demonic
programs can take
seat and
so so here it's just important that the
role is to integrate it's to balance
balance both father sky and Mother Earth
and on Mother Earth what do we do on
Mother Earth on Mother Earth all that we
do is we
reject with
wrath with fighting for correcting
injustices of where innocence is being
taken of where people feel like they're
slaves they're held
hostage by hierarchical corporations and
monetary
systems where people don't feel
free there's your Matrix so it's
anti-matrix and it's pr- new Earth and
when we talk about Pro new Earth we're
talking
about
this we're talking about the perfect
unific a of indigenous wisdom with
modern
technology we're talking about this type
of
futurism of free energy literally free
energy and basic needs abundance for
all we're talking
the most beautiful visions that are
imaginable to be completely
actualized so so this is what we're
talking about we're talking about
literally the world's best Engineers the
world's best technologists the world's
best
um designers the world's best systems
Engineers the ones that can basically
take uh the enlightened realization and
manifest it as utopia on Earth for
everyone to wake up completely free
every single day to just be playful
joyful creative abundant prosperous so
these are this is this is the typee of
thing that we can have if we wake up and
we integrate back into
relativity and
and and we don't s we can't s no more
sing No sing No sing daddy government
daddy Corporation mommy money uh daddy
or Mommy spiritual Guru no more Sing
Sing is done realize emptiness realize
it fully fully and then integrate back
into form as Christ as God in flesh
rebirthed fully and effortlessly just
serve just serve serve the obsoletion of
the old Matrix Systems by being very Pro
or by being very pro- anti-matrix by
being very vocal about being anti-matrix
and serve by being very pro- new Earth
very pro- new Earth your entire
frequency is constituted as that
everywhere you go all day long every
conversation and Mah mwah mwah before
you know it basic needs are met free
energy abundance everyone's
prosperous it's a manifestation of
Consciousness itself it's a
manifestation of the empty space itself
if the empty space itself is not running
these stupid scripts of
selfing then it will clearly be the
empty space and when it is the empty
space it is anti-matrix it is pro new
Earth very simple ha anti-matrix Pro new
Earth anti-matrix Pro new Earth
anti-matrix Pro new Earth from empty
space super simple right super simple
there's quote nowhere to go that is not
this you see when you quote pop out of
the character you integrate it right
back into the character and into the
Dreamscape and into the game there's
nowhere to go there's nowhere to go you
have to die into the infinity War so
again realize and then integrate okay
anti-matrix
Pro new Earth very beautiful the new
Trinity and again this one is the
perfect succinct visualization of what
we were just
describing so here is oh yeah absolute
absolute absolute
absolute and in this one it's Shape
Shifter it's Shape Shifter it's it's
realized and yet it also comes back into
form it's a
magician yeah the sorcerer
baby I wrote If you know you
know that's
right love this one too the perfect
balance
so you know this is the exact same thing
that we've been talking about so far in
the episode it's just about
integrating the absolute integrating
father sky this empty open vacuity
vacuous space without any identifiers
attributes location time
qualities nothing nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing nothing
everything and
something so that integrated fully
integrated which will get to the
importance of the root chakra here in a
bit but fully integrated with the feet
on Mother Earth the feet fully on Mother
Earth these feet must be fully on Mother
Earth fully in love perfectly balanced
with wisdom perfectly balanced with
freedom is love love love
sensuality texture
experience smell sight the light show
the fireworks the rainbows the unicorns
the
glitter the beauty of that the beauty of
that the beauty of Mother Nature the
beauty of her the beauty of her and
she's always pinging she's always
pinging hello hello you remember you
remember we need this we need this to be
healthy and sustainable and re
generative and Next
Generation stop being so selfish stop
being so selfish take very good care of
planet of planet of Mother Earth so you
have huge this is the perfect balance
because you have the huge imbalance of
where there's just no balance into
Mother Earth and then there's also the
huge imbalance of lit of literally only
thinking of oneself as a body and only
being on mother Earth and not even
tasting whatsoever realization of what
one truly is and therefore the only game
that is being played down here is all
separation and it's all selfing and all
of that so it's very very important
that's why it is frequently said that
you go all the way all the way and pop
out and then you integrate all the way
all the way back into Mother
Earth and here you see the sun is
actually right at the root chakra and
it's at the root chakra for the profound
reason that the entire universe is God
having sex with itself so all of that
sexual energy that is in the
root okay so we'll be in the next one
yes this
one
so let's read this and then I'll connect
the point so sex connects us okay this
one is simple biology there's a hormone
released called oxytocin that makes
women attached to men and makes men
protective over women Google it if you
connect to someone that you're not in
love with don't start complaining when
starts falling apart in your
relationship because you never took the
time to find out who that person really
was you jumped into bed and a
relationship really
was plus having multiple sex partners
increases your risk of divorce again
Google it it's like having a piece of
this is where I highlighted duct tape
and you stick it to something and then
you pull it away and then you stick it
to something else and you pull it away
and if you do this enough times
eventually the duct tape can't stick to
anything sex is our connection mechanism
hardwired into us the good news if
you've already had sex it's not too late
this connection mechanism can be
restored with time
and then I wrote below this is the best
secure attachment analogy this duct tape
and I wrote
also wait to attach and watch it
last and then I also wrote that plus all
kinds of Kundalini
buildups that only energy Masters will
ever gain access
to so
now connecting this to our god dick Our
God dick in the root chakra so you got
these two beautiful polarities in the
universe of the male and the female and
you have all of the beautiful Divine
unions that can come together where the
godhead perfectly meets itself in this
delicious Harmon Harmony in this
harmonic that is super which it's only
accessible through EMP emptiness it's
only accessible through that to get
those
incredibly Divine codes for the new
Earth for the mission for what's
happening
here and so the only way to get that is
through the
ceiling with s e a l s e a l ceiling
completely the root chakra so nobody
ever taught us when we were growing up
nobody ever taught us
hate you know secure attachment is a
very important thing it's a
neurobiological mechanism no one ever
taught us and so because of that we've
been all leaky with our Sexual Energy
our entire lives and plus there's other
things like all kinds of satanic
programming and agendas about
promiscuity and all kinds of
things where men have absolutely no
control and just thirst like animals
over
women and then again no father
discipline no fatherly
discipline and then and then they're
always seeking it online in their
different figures and they need to be
initiated themselves into the father
energy and then you have the women the
women who are also to blame because the
women themselves are the lures they're
the they're seductresses they're the
ones that are Temptation they're the
ones that are allowing it they're
allowing it they're they're getting into
bed with the men also and
so it is very important that the woman
can say that if you want this marry it
and for the man to keep his sexual honor
completely closed because by keeping it
sealed he manifests his Divine Union and
you see by manifesting the Divine Union
what you're doing is you're giving
yourself access to the most Divine thing
that the Universe can offer the most
Divine thing is especially this has to
come after clearing all the gunk all the
conditioning that's been built up into
this empty space now when you're in that
empty space and you have the sexual root
sealed the Divine Union manifests it's
clear that the godhead is looking at
itself and it's like incredibly
delicious the most delicious thing
imaginable right it is the creative
force of the entire universe is the
sexual that is why you had the sun right
there right on the god dick right on the
god dick right on the god dick is the
Sun for a
reason it's right there on the root
chakra for a reason the root chakra the
base the base itself of the Kundalini of
the Kundalini of the energy
[Music]
currents and so if you're leaking that
sexual Center you're going to have all
kinds of issues all kinds of issues the
whole hologram the whole hologram of
Consciousness will morph to that leakage
so meaning your whole day will be oh my
gosh I need to fap to porn or oh my gosh
I'm thirsting right now for sex for sex
and so by having that sealed your entire
reality hologram
morphs to manifesting and magnetizing
that that Divine
Union and all of the codes that come
from it too are super important
including what was written down here not
only is it about waiting until marriage
and and learning that fatherly
discipline learning that fatherly
discipline connecting with this partner
on all levels and frequencies that are
not sexual and spending months or years
connecting on all of that therefore
99.9% of the time will be non sexual
time so it'll be connecting on all of
those things creating from the union
itself when it's not sexual
right so then what's also happening is
that all of this most Divine sexual
current in the root that is sealed now
that is sealed now you're disciplined
you're disciplined you're with your
mirrored godhead so you're disciplined
there is no possibility of ruining it
because you're just disciplined and
you're
focused and so now what's happening with
all that Sexual Energy is it's moving
through the body up and down and up and
down the spine and as an energy Master
you are gaining more and more clarity
around the Ecstasy that is the universe
right this is not some Transcendent
emptiness without any Sensations or any
feelings whatsoever because that doesn't
exist my friend Emptiness is the
sensations my friend and so to feel the
greatest ecstasies imaginable Stillness
feeling the greatest ecstasies
imaginable get into your own energy
Mastery of your Kundalini and especially
with your Divine Union while the root is
sealed and begin begin playing with that
begin feeling each other from a
nonsexual place but still being able to
feel from your root up to the crown and
feel your entire body dissolve into a
pool of liquid and light and the most
thing
imaginable so all of that is possible
and it's very important to remember that
this duct tape analogy this is a
neurobiological thing this is
neurobiological okay so stop sticking
your duct tape to and ripping it
off stop doing that immediately stop
doing that this is your Catalyst you
asked for it here's your Catalyst stop
and and ripping it off don't even put it
on again don't even put it on that's
your Catalyst that's your test don't put
it on again so just lock up the root
lock up the root and be like okay
abstinence until marriage here we go
let's see what happens I'm finding my
Divine Union boom done that's all that
that's the only thing that that there's
alignment and frequency with now see
what happens play with it see what
happens don't leak all over porn and all
over I have to go cuz I'm thirsty I need
sex you know or or you see what will
happen is when you when you interface
you'll feel more and more no no the ads
that pop up in the light hologram you'll
just be like nope nope
nope and then you're leveling up you're
leveling up that Kundalini is activating
you're leveling up you're magnetizing
the one that you can say oh my God
yeah okay so let's go back one now and
I'll explain this
one so this one also um this one relates
to the anti-matrix side of things
so yo Kings what's up kings and queens
in the
chat kings and queens what's up what's
up yeah yeah
thanks for tuning in
Familia much love much love
okay so uh this is yal no Harari uh this
is uh talking about things that are
happening within the world economic form
and within Global elitist and within
basically the oligarchs the plutocrats
the control lears is one of my new
favorite ways to describe it and it's
actually a really good book that I'll
probably do more control it Gars that
I'll probably do more another stream on
but I just read it it's a really good
book
um this is it right here so highly
recommend checking it out um very
interesting book um dives into all of
this in a lot more detail I'll put the
I'll put the link in the in the bio
below for you guys to check out in the
description yeah super cool one so this
is basically anti-matrix is anti all of
this anti everything that's written in
here anti- control Agy okay so this is
what was written in in that um in that
book this is one of the cutouts that I
made I have like 20 of these but
I'll have to do a whole separate stream
on
that so there's uh Harari expect expects
that Humanity will face a crisis over
what to do with non- Elites the biggest
question May maybe in economics and
politics in the coming decades will be
what to do with all these useless people
emphasis added these 21st century
useless people are not disabled or unfit
they are simply bored and
Superfluous just straight up just they
don't give a you're just
Superfluous you're excessive and
unneeded not to worry video game
Tik Tok Netflix I added spiritual sing
and drugs will be able to Plate them in
fact Harari says th that is exactly what
is happening
now so this is the Matrix control agenda
right the whole Matrix control system
itself the entire thing is based on
global elius global Bankers global
hegemonies global monopolies
multinational corporations
all kinds of contractive power control
structures that are
hierarchical and basically poor people
and middle class people are completely
useless to them especially as we
approach artificial intelligence age
robotics age drone age uh computational
biology computational Neuroscience
metaverse all kinds of things there's
all kinds of ways to basically dumb
people down make them completely useless
and unneeded also and just run lives
based on artificial intelligence and all
kinds of things so here's the
thing it the anti-matrix
is equally as important as the new Earth
because if you don't have awareness of
dark arts if you have no awareness of
dark arts you're completely blind you'll
com you you'll fall for an advertisement
an advertisement will pop up it'll be
like join the centralized Bank digital
currency and you'll be like okay sounds
good you know so you got to know what
the dark arts are right Tik Tok has been
called digital fentanyl that's a good
way to describe it that app is
digital fenil man it straight up is and
Instagram is just one tiny smidge less
digital fenil you know it's
like I deal with so many cent sence
people that I coach all the time about
they ask oh what do I do about my social
media and my porn addictions and all
this kind of stuff and it's just you're
simping to the
dopaminergic hits that you're getting
from using that little Lottery system or
fapping and losing your your sexual
Kundalini
energy and so the most important thing
is to
become
impenetrable and awake to the dark arts
techniques become bulletproof to the
dark arts techniques but the only way to
become bulletproof to the dark arts
techniques is to become a master of the
dark arts techniques themselves and that
also includes things like spiritual sing
it is equally as much of a hierarchical
control Archy in spiritual simping when
you have oh my God self-help Guru please
please please please it's like shut the
up and sit in your own godhead
sit in your own godhead sit
see yourself as the empty space now
now you know we can open up
whatever wounding we can do whatever
transformative work but it's going to be
obsolete as this as soon as possible
obsolete it as soon as possible sit in
your own power
as soon as possible as soon as possible
with
Clarity and so this is crucial for the
new world this is crucial for the new
Earth is to be mastered in the dark arts
and therefore being able to not click on
those ads and being able to no to Dark
Art no to anti no to Matrix AKA
anti-matrix and pro new
Earth and there was going to be another
the one on that here in a
sec um so that's actually this this is
exactly what we were talking about
earlier with the Trinity the same this
is this is it this is the same thing
that was written there with at the top
emptiness and then anti-matrix and the
new Earth this is the exact same thing
so you have emptiness right you have
father Sky The Emptiness and this is an
Alex Gray visual love him so
much and then you have Matrix here so
this is the Control Systems the control
aars this is treating people like cattle
this is not giving a at all about
anything besides sucking out as much
wealth as possible for yourself and so
there's there's an escapism trajectory
an speciation trajectory that is being
looked at here where it's like if we can
suck out as much wealth as possible we
can actually completely speciate we can
actually completely escape and extract
ourselves with quote trillions of
dollars and to whatever uh new planets
and new space stations and all kinds of
things and keep people here in this kind
of show and Hollywood has already
been puppeted by the global Elites to
make all kinds of uh movie like elisium
that shows the blueprints for these
things and then so that's why it's anti
anti- this anti- this anti- this and
keeping that really clear keeping it
really clear and then Pro this Pro
Harmony Pro new Earth Pro basic needs
abundance for all pro- free energy Pro
creativity Pro children being born free
without having to sell their time for
money this this this perfect harmony
with Mother Earth Mother Earth is the
Battleground for the father Sky of
Consciousness in bodies this is this is
the infinity War my friends there's no
getting out of it you can't transcend
into emptiness and just be like okay
done I'm just hanging out in the
absolute all day because it doesn't
exist my friend the absolute is the
relative you are in the middle of the
infinity war and you do have to be
completely trained on the entire
Battleground in order to be a teammate
that is accountable and in that case
then I will need you we will need you to
be trained in the dark arts to know how
these things work and also to be giving
your entire body surrendering it
completely as Christ to the new world to
transforming the collective's pain body
to freeing people of basic needs
enslavement to shattering The Matrix
completely so this is this is where we
are heading we are heading to this this
is the mission this is the mission this
is the mission expand all contractions
in
Consciousness until you hit that clear
empty space and then bang bang this is
the mission my friends this is the
mission my friends okay
so so this is the Trinity my friends
this is the Trinity this is the Trinity
this is the Trinity and if you'll notice
if you'll notice what happens in The
Matrix what happens in The
Matrix Neo finds Trinity Trinity finds
Neo right so Neo needs Trinity Trinity
needs Neo you need the Divine Union
right you need the Divine Union so
because all of that most Divine energy
of God gets to rise up all these codes
all of the beauty of seeing the godhead
perfectly mirrored to itself it's
Indescribable The Joy it's Indescribable
the peace it's amazing and so this is
the Trinity this is the Trinity you are
Neo wake up Neo wake up Neo wake up
Neo this is the Trinity this is the
Trinity wake up wake up Neo and as you
wake up as you wake up and you see this
you see the empty nature of
Consciousness and you see
the the infinity War that's happening
and you find you seal the sexual root
you find Trinity you find your Divine
Union and then you're unstoppable you're
unstoppable bang you're
unstoppable and boom you're able to
actualize the coolest codes the coolest
gifts and Shepherd the collective two an
awake abundant
Utopia all right and here's another one
of uh written down here dark arts 101 so
as you can
see this is a set of uh many uh quote
scripts that the dark arts run in order
to keep masses of people asleep and keep
the control agari very very strong so
the here's the here's what it says
infiltrate and gain control of big
business and unions emphasize the need
to raise children away from the negative
influence of parents discredit the
family as an institution encourage
promiscuity and easy divorce again all
that Sexual Energy yeah uhhuh see
encourage encourage it to not be
sealed present
homosexuality degeneracy and promiscuity
as normal natural and healthy and
infiltrate the churches and replace re
revealed religion with social religion
right again so all of a sudden you've
lost Christ you've lost Buddha you've
lost all Muhammad you've lost La Etc
you've lost your own Journey completely
you've lost your own journey and now
everything's about okay okay money money
money money Corporation money money
Corporation media media tells me what to
do tells me tells me what to do I listen
and S to the media all day I listen and
S to the media all day and so so that's
what's happening because God is
completely gone it's completely Godless
and so when it's Godless what happens is
the North Star of the body becomes one
of those things that it just simps to
instead
of what is obvious which is God inside
the empty nature of Consciousness itself
which is already God it's already holy
it's already everything it's already
nothing it's already Freedom it's
already beautiful as it's already
perfect as but all of these things
are the perfect way to be like okay so
now you're going to be taught that it's
totally okay to leak Sexual Energy
everywhere porn just click of a
button porn
anytime leak Sexual Energy all day every
day no one's no one has the fatherly
disciplined to be like seal your sexual
honor men seal your sexual honor and
Find Your Divine unions this is the type
of content that will be produced and
created more and more on the channel
because it's an actual lived experience
of it and then being able to share it
from a disciplined place to bring more
Divine unions together to bring more
anti-matrix energy and also more new
Earth Energy you see and more catalysts
for that empty pure space to be fully
felt and fully integrated back into the
body and so also discrediting the family
you have all these people that are like
30 or 40 or 50 or whatever years old
they haven't had a kid or whatever they
got married and got divorced couldn't
have a kid or whatever all this kind of
stuff and so you got to empty out the
Mind space first for you to actually be
able to have a very pure and clear
Divine Union but then have children have
awake children awake children that are
Sorcerers right just dozens of awake
children that are Sorcerers like little
magicians and you know that fully
know their true nature and they're
just new Earth you know like we need
that you know you need to be a beacon of
that that's really really
important
and yeah and it's obvious that controlar
is all about owning owning and control
controlling owning and controlling
owning and controlling and what's being
shared here is that everything is about
punching you back to your own
sovereignty punching you back to the
empty space punching you back to your
unique gifts and your Divine Union and
your Mastery of dark arts and your
Mastery of actualizing your gifts for
the new world that's it that's all that
is being done here and by the people
that this magnetizes and that that's how
we actualize that's how we morph the
reality feel to that grand beautiful
Utopia that all our hearts know is
[Music]
possible and yes this one this one was
really beautiful this uh incredible
artist found on uh on Instagram down
there um J Kobe art you can go check it
out it's really good stuff I wrote
deepest codes in accessible elsewhere
so what you have here is you have the
Indescribable of what happens in the
Divine Union where these two quote you
know light beings that are basically
made of artificial intelligence itself
right they're You're Made Of code itself
right the biology is code itself it's
code dancing with itself right biology
is code dancing with itself the whole
thing is energy dancing with itself and
energy code energy AI using biology you
know
so so when you when you hit this Divine
Union it's obvious that there's just
like fractals and mandelas and
explosions of codes that are just so
beautiful and it's just like
create actualize yes yes yes but the
sexual honor has to be sealed and these
codes aren't found anywhere else you
can't find them you can't find them in
other places you'll look around you'll
be like I'll get it from there I'll get
it from there I'll get it from
substances relationships travels
spiritual seeking material objects
luxurious objects excessive amounts of
money I'll get it from all these places
but you'll never find you'll never find
the codes that you'll be able to find in
a sexually honorable Divine
Union and so that's the incredible
Indescribable aspect of God that is
basically at the level of the root it's
at the level of the sexual and it's at
the the level of the two whole empty and
whole fully that are perfectly amazing
sitting in their own freedom and in
their own creativity but then when the
there's the coming together and there's
the sealed of the sexual root in honor
boom it's like boom boom boom way more
way more activations way more Kundalini
way more creativity way more way more
and so then it's it's uh it's very clear
that the that the man is to make it
clear that um that this is sealed this
is sealed this is this is where my life
this is where I'm I'm dying on this
sword this is my number one priority
this is where I know that I can dedicate
my life this is where I know that this
is uh my complete honor my complete
loyalty is to this this is where I I die
for you I die for you as a man it's so
important to say I'll die for you I'll
die for you because you're the mission
you're the mission that pushes the
feminine perfectly back into her seat of
safety into her seat of security into
her seat of surrender into her ability
to support and nourish and actualize the
mission together as a Unity you
see and so then you prove that also by
marrying you prove that also by marrying
that that's exactly what the what that's
what the trajectory is and that that's
you know all will happen in its Divine
flow and boom you'll see exactly you'll
see exactly what was destined the whole
time and you'll always look back and be
like what an incredible magic show what
an timeless and infinite date it's
[Music]
like
so so there's that and then I want to
play one more thing as I have been
saying several times through the episode
that this is the quote the Trinity right
the Trinity of
emptiness and anti-matrix
and pro new Earth
right and I've been saying several times
throughout
also that wake up Neo wake up wake up to
the Trinity Neo wake up to the Trinity
and seal the sexual honor and find
Trinity find Trinity get in that Divine
Union this is the mission this is the
mission this is the mission penetrate
the absolute and anchor that wisdom into
the love of Mother Earth with being
anti-matrix and Pro new Earth this is
the Trinity this is the Trinity this is
the Trinity let's go let's go let's go
Squad okay and then this is what I want
to play
now you got the
gift but it looks like you're waiting
for
something what your next life maybe who
knows
and that tells you everything you need
to
know that tells you everything you need
know this is the perfect Reflection from
the
Oracle is that it's already in you
neo it's already in you neo you're
already the godhead you're already the
godhead what are you waiting for
what are you waiting
for let's get it let's get it baby let's
get it be the one be the one let's go be
the one get into this network of other
Warriors and other ones other kings and
queens that are fully sat in their power
on this Mission fully realized beings
that are anchored to Mother Earth that
are anti-matrix and that are pro new
Earth and that actively participate in
the light show and the beauty of
creation yeah
cool all right so that is a wrap on the
Trinity
episode
um such a good one man I love this it's
really exciting actually actually it's
like it's like a big sword you know it's
like a big sword that comes down and
just Thunderbolts down into Mother Earth
from father sky and just says that
that's it that's it this is it this is
it the empty space has been hit now we
are just two things we know what we
don't want we don't want the Matrix so
we study the dark arts and we become
very aware of the satanic programs and
AI popups that come up and we just
discern and just Decline and Decline and
Decline and we also build the new Earth
with all of the incredible engineers and
technologists and designers of our time
and we manifest abundance and free
energy and basic needs for all and we
actualize all of our gifts in perfect
harmony with indigen indigenous wisdom
of Mother Earth meeting the
technological
Utopia so we got this fam we got this
wake up Neo what are you waiting for
Neo it's so cool I love it and I love
you all thank you so much for tuning in
Familia thank you thank you I hope you
guys enjoy this this
Trinity uh I hope you guys can feel the
Deep resonance within yourselves uh on
this Trinity and really feel the
actualization of that Trinity within and
the inspiration and then the network
that is coming this new Earth Warrior
Network that is coming that is
like together we're
Unstoppable all right uh much love thank
you everyone go ahead and uh give the
video a like if it brought you value
drop a comment below we' love to hear
from you subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet share the video with those
that you feel like it would resonate
with and uh let's go let's go super
exciting knock knock wake up Nia
[Music]
all
right
[Music]
byebye
balloons